ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้นักเรียนน่ะสวัสดีนัก
เรียนครับน่ะสวัสดีครับคุณเพื่อน
อ้าวๆสวัสดีทุกคนนะวันนี้เรามาเรียนภาษา
ไทยกับพี่อาตี้แล้วก็น้องเรียมกันนะครับ
เหมือนเดิมเลยใช่เควันนี้เรามาเจอกันใน
วันอังคารขอวันนี้เป็นวันอังคารใช่ไหม
ครับวันนี้เป็นวันอังคารโอเควันอังคาร
มาหาวันอังคารอยู่ตรงไหนครับนี่วันนี้วัน
อังคารวันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่ครับวันอังคาร
ที่ 12 วันนี้วันอังคารที่ 12 นะ 5 เดือน
เดือนตุลาคมเดือนนี้เดือน
ตุลาคมหมอเคแค่นี้ครับเดือนตุลาคมแล้วปี
ปี
ปีพ.ศ.ปีคศอะไรครับปีคศ 2000  21 อ๋อปีคศ
2010  21 นะครับอ่าปีนี้ปีนี้ปีคศ 2000
21  5 แล้วพ.ต.ต.นะครับผชอะไรครับพ.ศ
2506  14
2564 ว้าวปีนิพพศ 2560  4-5 วันนี้อ้วน
อังคารวันอังคารที่ 12 นะครับวันอังคาร
ที่ 12 เดือนตุลาคมพ.ศ 2020 เอ็ดเรา
มาเรียนภาษาไทยกับเปียตีกับน้องเรียมกัน
หรอโอเค
จังเลยอ้าไปเรียนกันครับไปเรียนกันก็
เดี๋ยวก่อนครับก่อนที่จะเรียนเฮียตีก็
อยากรู้ด้วยอยากรู้ว่าตอนนี้ตอนนี้กี่โมง
แล้วครับ
อ้านี้ตอนนี้กี่โมงนะครับตอนนี้
8:00 นค่ะอ๋ออ๋อตอนนี้ 8 โมงนี่ 8 โมง
ตรงนี้นะครับ 8 โมงตรงใช่ไหมครับอ่า 8:00
น 8:00 นตรงหน้าเข็มยาวตรงนี้ 8 โมงนะอ่า
ชายครับ
8:00 น 8:00 นน่าใช้ครับ 8:00 นครับ
วันนี้เราจะมาพูดเกี่ยวกับเรื่องเงินขอ
เงินว้าววันนี้มีเงินกูอันนี้เป็นอะไร
ครับเนี่ยเป็นเงินใช่ไหมใช่ครั้งเงินเงิน
โอเควันนี้น้องเรียนมีเงินมาเยอะเลยเนี่ย
เงินเหรียญ
มีเงินเรียนด้วยใช่ไหมครับว้าวมีหลาย
เหรียญเลยมีเหรียญอะไรบ้างครับอ๋อถ้าเป็น
เหรียญขอดูเหรียญหน่อย
ผมขอดูเหรียญใหม่เหรียญบาทค่ะอ๋ออ๋อนี่
หน้าเหรียญบาทเหรียญบาทเป็นแบบนี้นะครับ
เหรียญบาทก็จะเป็นเหรียญกลมๆใช่ไหมครับ
ใช้ค่ะลักษณะกลมแบบนี้น่ะเดี๋ยวพี่วาด
เหรียญกลมๆให้นี่เหรียญพร้อมกลัวๆเปลี่ยน
ตีวาดไม่ค่อยกลมเท่าไหร่นะแต่เป็นเหรียญ
บาทใช่ไหมเหรียญบาทปีเลข 1 อยู่ตรงกลาง
ใช่มั้ยเหรียญ 1 บาท OK  1 บาทแล้วมี
เหรียญอะไรอีกครับมีเหรียญ 2 บาทมีเหรียญ
2 บาทด้วยว้าวหน้ามีเหรียญเหรียญ 2 บาท
เนาะมันไม่เหมือนกันเหรียญบาทกับเหรียญ 2
บาทไม่เหมือนกันเหรียญบาทมีสีอะไรครับ
เมื่อกี้อ๋อนี่ไงเหรียญบ้านเหรียญบ้าน
เป็นสีเงินใช่ไหม
เงินอ๋อเหรียญบาทเป็นสีเงินแล้วก็มีขนาด
เป็นไงครับอ่ะมีนาดเล็กกว่า
เล็กกว่าเหรียญ 2 บาทหรอแล้วเหรียญ 2 บาท
สีอะไรครับสีเหลืองค่ะสีเหลืองอ้อเป็นสี
เหลืองใช่ไหมอ๋อนี่คือความแตกต่างแตกต่าง
กันของเหรียญบาทแล้วก็เหรียญ 2 บาทเหรียญ
2 บาทจะใหญ่กว่าใช่ไหมใหญ่กว่าว่าแล้วก็
มีสีอื่นอ๋อถ้าเป็นเหรียญบาทก็จะเล็กกว่า
เหรียญบาทเล็กกว่าแล้วก็มีสีเงินว้าวโอเค
มีเหรียญ 1 บาทเหรียญ 2 บาทแล้วมีเหรียญ
อะไรอีกครับพี่เหรียญ 5 บาทก็มีเหรียญ 5
บาทด้วยอ่ะเหรียญ 5 บาทโอเคเหรียญ 5 บาท
ก็มีหาเหรียญ 5 บาทก็จะใหญ่ใหญ่กว่าใช่
ไหมใหญ่กว่าเหรียญใช่มั้ยอ๋อ S  P  Arty
สังเกตเห็นบนเหรียญเนี่ยมีรูปคนอยู่ข้อ
มูลเหรียญมีรูปคนอยู่ใช่ขันรู้เปลี่ยน
เป็นใครครับใครอยู่บนเหรียญนับเป็นรูป
ในหลวงค่ะอ๋ออ๋อในเอ้ยในหลวงเหรอครับได้
หลวงคืออะไรเขาต้องเรียวคือมหากษัตริย์
แต่ว่าเป็นพิงของประเทศไทยอ๋อเป็นพระราชา
ของประเทศไทยหอนี่เป็นรูปของพระราชาอยู่
ในอยู่ในเหรียญหรออยู่ในเหรียญของเขียนขอ
โทษเรียนค่ะอ๋อ
มีรูป
พระราชาอยู่ในเหรียญใช่มั้ยอ๋อโอเคด้าน
หนึ่งนะครับอีกด้านหนึ่งอีกด้านหนึ่ง
หนึ่งก็จะเป็นสัญลักษณ์
ขอ
เป็นสัญลักษณ์สัญลักษณ์คือเป็นรูปที่ใช้
แทนมาถึงพระราชาใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อเป็น
สัญลักษณ์นะไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่พระราชานะแต่เป็น
สัญลักษณ์เป็นรูปอ่าเครื่องหมายเครื่อง
หมายที่ใช้แทนพระราชาอ๊อดก็อยู่อีกด้าน
หนึ่งได้ไหมครับอ๋อ
โอเค
หนาวเลขถ้าที่เราเห็นนะคะก็จะเป็นเลข 5
ไทยอ๋ออ๋อเป็นเลข 5 ไทยถ้าเป็นเลข 5 ปกติ
ก็จะเป็นเลข 5 แบบนี้ใช่ไหมอ่ะแต่ถ้าเป็น
เลข 5 ไทยเลข 5 ไทยจะเป็นเลข 5 แบบนี้
หน้านี้เป็นเลข 5 ไทยผอนี่คือเลข 5 ใช่
ไหมให้ 5 นักเรียนต้องสังเกตให้ดีนะครับ
ถ้าบนเรียนเนี้ยจะมีเลขที่เป็นเลขไทยด้วย
น้าาใครค่ะมีทั้งเลขไทยนะครับหน้าเราก็
เลข
อาหารบิ๊กอารบิกระเบิ 5 เลขอโรบิก k5 มี
เหรียญบาทหนึ่งบาทมีเหรียญ 2 บาทเหรียญ
ห้าบาทแล้วของประเทศไทยยังมีเหรียญอะไร
ที่ไหนกันอยู่อีกครับมีเหรียญ 10
ว้าวๆนี้เหรียญ 10 เหรียญ 10 บาทเหรียญ 10
บาทโอ้เหรียญ 10 บาทเหรียญ 10 บาทมี 2 สี
เลยพี่อาร์ตี้เห็นว่ามันมี 2 สีอยู่ในค่ะ
อ๋อ
เหรียญ 10 บาทมีสีเงินแล้วก็สีเหลืองอยู่
ตรงกลางใช่ไหมขอ
10 บาทแล้วก็ๆยังมีพระราชาอยู่ในเหรียญ
เหมือนเดิมใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะเราก็มี
สัญลักษณ์ด้านหลัง
โอเคแต่ว่าอันนี้เหรียญ 10 เนี่ยเขาจะตัว
เลข 10 ไว้ใช่ไหมครับใช่ค่ะเขียนเลข 10
มีทั้งเลขไทยและก็เลขอารบิอ๋ออ๋อมีทั้ง
เลขไทยแล้วก็เล็กอ่ะบิดด้วยเหมือนกันได้
แล้วเหรียญ 10 นี่ขนาดใหญ่หรือขนาดเล็ก
ครับขนาดใหญ่ค่ะใหญ่ๆเขาใหญ่ที่สุดเลยใช่
มั้ยหอในคอดูหน่อยขอดูเหรียญ 10 กับ
เหรียญ 5 หน่อยอ้านี่เปลี่ยนสิบๆเดี๋ยว
สี่สิบห้างอ่ะโอเคโอเคโอเคมันต่างกัน
เพราะว่าเฮียตีเห็นว่าเปลี่ยน 10 เมตรจะ
มีสีเหลืองอยู่ตรงกลางเดือน 5 ไม่มีสี
เหลืองอ้อโอเคมีกี่ความแตกต่างกันนะครับ
โอเคอ่ะเหรียญหน้าคนไทยเราใช้เหรียญใช้
เหรียญแล้วก็มีเงินแบบไหนครับมีเงินที่
เรียกว่าธนบัตร
หมอมีผู้ชนะป่ะด้วยธนบัตรที่ยากจังชื่อ
เลี่ยงยากต่างธนบัตรคนไทยทั่วไปเรียกว่า
แดงอ๋อ
ธนบัตรหรือเราจะเรียกว่าแบงค์ก็ได้นะ
แบงค์เป็นชื่อเล่นใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะชื่อเล่น
ของธนบัตรแล้วแค่อ่ะอ่าอันนี้เป็นแบงค์นะ
แบงค์อะไรครับแบงค์นี้แบงค์ 20 ค่ะก็
แบงค์ 20
ออกนี่เพียงตีเห็นเห็นมีตัวเลขตัวเลขให้
อยู่ด้วยใช่ไหมครับแบงค์ก็มีเลขไทยใช่ไหม
อ๋ออันนี้คือใคร
เลข 2 ของไทยแล้วก็เป็นเลข 0 อยู่ใกล้ๆ
กันเรียกว่า 20 ปีคุณแบงค์เลขอะไรเบิอ๋อ
อ๋อมีเลขอารบิกอยู่ด้วยเหมือนกันว้าวคะ
อันนี้แบงค์ 20 นี่นี่ห่อมีสีสีอะไรครับ
เนี่ยที่ออกสีเขียวนะคะเที่ยวใช่ไหมอ๋อ
อ๋อแบงค์ 20 จะเป็นสีเขียวอ่ะเขียวแล้วใน
รูปมีอ้อนี่เป็นก็เป็นรูปของพระราชา
เหมือนเดิมใช่ไหมครับเหมือนกันใช่ไหมคะ
รู้ของพระราชา
รัชกาลที่ 10 ขอ
รัชกาลที่ 10 ก็คือพระราชาคนที่ 15 ของ
ประเทศไทยอ๋อโอเคอ๋อพระราชาหล่อจังเลยอ่ะ
ด้านมี
แบงค์ 20 แล้วด้านหลังแบงค์ 20 มีอะไร
ครับเปียตี้อยากเห็นอ๋อ
ด้านหลังโอ้ด้านหลังก็มีพระราชาเหมือนกัน
ใช่ไหมเนี่ยไปค่ะมีพระราชทานกัน
เป็นพระราชาคนเก่าชนเก่าและ 5 เป็นพระ
ราชาคนที่ 1
ราชาคนที่ 1 ของประเทศไทยโว่นานมากเลยทาน
มากหรอกแล้วก็อีกคนนึงอีกคนหนึ่งเป็นใคร
ครับเด็กไม่แน่ใจเหมือนกันนะคะคนที่ 2
เหมือนกันนะนะอีกคนหนึ่งพระราชาคนที่สอง
ครับเป็นพระพุทธเลิศหล้านภาลัยนะฮะคนที่ 1
ที่ 2 คนที่ชายคนที่ 1 คนที่ 2 อยู่คู่
กันอา
จะด้านนี้ก็เป็นคนที่ 10 คนมาหาคน
ปัจจุบันคนที่ 10 คนตอนนี้คนที่เป็นพระ
ราชาอยู่ตอนนี้หาหมอก็ดีก็คือ 20 ใช่ไหม
แบงค์ 25  20 อ่ามีค่า 20 บาทแบงค์ 20
แบงค์ที่มีค่ามากกว่านี้นะคะอ๋ออ๋อครับผม
หน้าอาเฮียที่มีแบงค์ 50 ไหมคะแบงค์ 50
ใช่ไหมเดี๋ยวนะพี่ดูก่อน๊โปตีก็มีเงิน
เยอะยังรู้
แบงค์สบายดีครับมีแบงค์ 50 ไหนมีเลข 5
เลข 50 นี่เป็นภาษาไทยมีเลขไทย 5 และก็ 0
เป็น 50 แบงค์ 50 มีแล้วก็มีพระราชาอยู่
เหมือนกันนี่พระราชาอยู่ตรงนี้ประชาคน
ปัจจุบันนะคุณประชาฟัน 5 แล้วก็มีเลข 5
10 อยู่ตรงนี้ครับว้าวได้ชา
ต้นสีฟ้า
25 แบงค์ 50 เป็นสีฟ้าแบบนี้นี่ครับ
น่าสนแบงค์ 20 เป็นสีเขียว
สีเขียวและสีฟ้าอาดูความแตกต่างโอเคมี
แบงค์ 50 แล้ว
ไป 50 ก็จะเขียนเลข 50 ไว้นะครับอ่ะโอเค
แล้วก็แบงค์ 40 ก็เขียนเลข 20 แล้วมี
แบงค์อะไรอีกครับเตรียมมีแบงค์แบงค์ร้อย
ค่ะอ๋ออ๋อแบงค์ร้อยโอเคแบงค์ร้อยก็เหมือน
กันเลยแต่ว่าต่างกันตรงที่ต่างกันตรงไหน
บ้างครับต่างกับแบงค์ 50 ต่างกับแบงค์ 20
ตรงไหนบ้างหมอต่างที่ศรีขอนี่ต่างกันที่ 4
หน้าแบงค์ 100  800 จะเป็นสีแดงอ๋อเป็นสี
แดงอ่านี่แบงค์ร้อยเป็นสีแดงแล้วก็มีตัว
เลขตัวเลขเป็นเลข
100 ใช่ไหมครับทั้งเลขไทยและเลขอะไรเบิ
อ๋ออ๋อเลขอะไรเปลี่ยนใหม่
100 มีเลข 1 มีเลข 1 แล้วก็เล็ก 0  2
ตัวเลข 1 ของไทยเขียนกลมๆอย่างนี้ใช่ค่ะ
อ่ะก็เพราะว่าค่ะพี่กลมมาพี่อาร์ตี้เขียน
ไม่เหมือนเดี๋ยวนะเขียนไม่สวยนี่เดี๋ยว
เอาใหม่เอาใหม่นี้นี่
เล็ก 1  0
เลขศูนย์เราเขียนเหมือนกันน่ะเลข 0 ไทย
กับเลข 0 อารบิกเหมือนกันอ่ามีเลข 2 ตัว
นะครับหน้า 100 ว้าวแบงค์ร้อยโอเค
แล้วด้านหลังด้านหลังออกมีรูปพระราชาราชา
เหมือนกันอ้อแต่คนนี้ออกหน้าไม่เหมือนกับ
คนเมื่อกี้แล้ว
คนละคนกันใช่ไหมครับคนละคนค่ะอันนี้เป็น
พระราชารัชกาลที่ 5
รัชกาลที่ 5 ครับเดี๋ยวพี่พอจะรู้ไหมคะ
ว่า
ข้างๆ
อีกคนหนึ่งก็เป็นรัชกาลที่ 6 ครับขอ
ราชการที่ 6 ครับรัชกาลที่ 6 ใช่เขาพระ
สมเด็จพระมงกุฎเกล้าเจ้าอยู่โอเครัชกาล
ที่ 6 พ.ค.อ่ะต่อไปครับมีแบงค์อะไรอีก
ครับเพียบที่มีแบงค์ 500 บาทมั้ยคะอ๋ออ๋อ
แบงค์ 500 ใช่ไหมมี
นี้มีแบงค์ 500 อยู่นี่ครับแบงค์ 500
เป็นสีอะไรเมื่อกี้แบงค์ 100 สีแดงใช่ไหม
นี่แบงค์ร้อยสีแดงแบงค์ 500 เป็นสีเป็นสี
ม่วงๆครับเป็นสีม่วงแล้วก็มีเลข 500
เหมือนเดิมนี่ไวมือพี่อาร์ตี้บังนี่เลข
500 มีเลข 5
1 ตัวแล้วก็เลข 0  2 ตัวนี้เป็นเลขอารบิ
นะแล้วก็อีกข้างนึงก็จะเป็นเลขไทยอ่ะอ่า
นี่ครับเป็นเลขไทยแล้วก็มีพระราชาคนเดิม
ครับพระราชาคนถ้าได้ที่บันคนปัจจุบันเป็น
พระราชารัชกาลที่ 10 คนที่ 10
ใช้ครับอ้าน้องเองถัดรู้อยากดูด้านหลัง
ไหมถ้าท่านถังมีใครดูด้านหลังมีใครมีสัน
หลังมีพระราชาองค์เก่า on เรียมพอรู้
ใจครับนี่องค์นี้องค์นี้เป็นใครครับพรุ่ง
นี้เอานี้ก่อนนะที่ไม่ตรงเอาแค่ของนี้
ครับเป็นราชการที่ 7 หรือเปล่าคะถูกต้อง
ครับเป็นรัชกาลที่ 7 แน่รัชกาลที่ 7 ได้
ครับมีพระราชารัชกาลที่ 8 ใต้ครับอีกองค์
หนึ่งก็เป็นรัชกาลที่ 8 นี้ตรงนี้รัชกาล
ที่ 8 อายุหลังแบงค์
500 บาท 100 ไลค์ครับ
แบงค์ 500 นะครับแล้วก็เดี๋ยวนะมีแบงค์
500 แล้วมีอะไรอีกครับมีแบงค์พันค่ะมี
แบบคนไทยมีแบงค์เยอะจังเลยพี่แบงค์เยอะ
จังเลยมีแบงค์ยันใบทันไหมคะพี่แบงค์พัน
ไม่ห้ามเพียงดีไม่มีแต่เบียร์ตีเนี่ยมี
รูปแบงค์พันอยู่อ่ะเดี๋ยวพี่เอารูปอันมา
ให้ดูนะครับว่าหน้าตาเป็นยังไงนะครับอ่ะ
แบงค์พันก็จะมีหน้าตาเป็นแบบนี้ครับแบบ
นี้แบบนี้นี่ไงนี่คือแบงค์พันใช่ครับ
แบงค์พันมีสีอะไรค่ะพี่อติแบงค์พันมีสี
น้ำตาล
นะครับอ่านี่ทานหน้าเนอะแล้วก็มีเลข 1,000
เป็นภาษาไทยให้เป็นเลขไทยอยู่ตรงนี้เล็ก
หนึ่งแล้วก็เล็ก
0005 เป็น 1,000 แบงค์นี้มีค่ามีค่า
1,000 นะครับหน้าโอเคแล้วก็อ้ามีพระราชา
พระราชาองค์ที่ 10 อายุด้านหน้าด้านหลัง
ครับด้านหลังมีพระราชาเหมือนกันแต่เป็น
พระราชโอรสและสุดท้ายนะครับที่เรายังไม่
ได้พูดถึงในแบงค์ก็คือองค์ที่
9 และแม
มีพระราชาองค์ที่ 9 อยู่ด้านหลังแบงค์พัน
ใช่ครับว่าหน้าหา
แม่เรียมได้ยินได้ยินคนไทยพูดว่า
อันนี้เป็นแบงค์ 20
ครับอันนี้เป็นแบงค์ร้อยครับคนไทยไม่ไม่
พูดว่าแบงค์ 100 บาทอ๋อใช่คนไทยชอบเพียบ
สั้นๆออกเรียกชื่อสั้นๆใส่เขาก็เลยเรียก
ว่าแบงค์ร้อยห้าร้อยๆครับ
จะมีมูลค่า
100  100 บาทได้ครับสั้นๆว่าแบงค์ร้อย
ตายก็ได้ครับหน้ามันแดงพันค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้
อ้าใช่แบงค์พันเราก็เรียกเราก็ไม่เรียก
ว่าแบงค์ 1,000 บาทไม่เรียกคนไทยไม่ชอบ
เรียกยาวันไหนเรียกตั้นๆแบงค์พันหน้าเป็น
แบงค์พันใช้ขับ
แล้ว
แบบนี้
ครับร้อยแบงค์ร้อย
แบงค์ร้อยอยู่ 2 แบงค์ 5 แบงค์ 100  2
แบงค์ครับใช่
แล้วเรียงก็มีเหรียญ 10 อยู่
เหรียญ 10
อาหาอยู่ 3 เหรียญ 3 เหรียญโอเคครับใช่
ค่ะแล้วก็มีเหรียญ 5
มีเหรียญ 5 ซึ่งชื่อกิเรียนคะพี่อาร์ตี้
เหรียญ 5  4 เหรียญมีเหรียญ
50  4v ๆไปครับมีเหรียญ 2 บาท
น้อเหรียญ 2 บาทสีเหลือง 2 เหรียญ 2
เหรียญค่ะ
เตรียมก็จะเอามาหยอดกระปุกออมสินเอามาใส่
ลงไปในกระปุกใช่ไหมอ๋อแต่พี่อ่ะเลียมไม่
ได้พูดว่าใส่น้องเรียนพูดว่าหยอดหน้ายอด
ก็คือการเอาเหรียญใส่ลงไปใส่ลงไปในกระปุก
ใช่มั้ยอ๋อ
ก็เลยเรียกว่าหยอดกระปุกหอ
กระปุกหยอดกระปุก
ยอมรับอุก
หยอดกระปุกโอเคว้าวยอดรถเฮ้ยให้เรียมหยอด
กระปุกๆ
เอาไว้ยอดครับมีเหรียญ 10 เตรียมหยอดไม่
ลงหน้าขอบคุณเถอะค่ะได้แล้ว
งั้นเอาอีกคราวนี้ที่ได้ที่อีก
เดี๋ยวพี่มีเหรียญสิบเยอะเอาไปอีก
ทำไมกลายเป็นเหรียญ 5 อ้าว
เอา KR ยอดด้วยครับยอดเกือบ
โอเคอ๋ออ๋อแล้วแบงค์หยอดได้ไหมครับยอดได้
ค่ะ
เราก็เอามาเอามาเอาอ๋ออ้าว
โอเค
อ๋อโอเคครับเราก็จะพักผับเราต้องครับใช่
ไหมครับ
เราต้องพับพับให้มันเล็กเล็กใช่ไหมเพราะ
ว่าเพราะว่ามันจะได้หยอดลงไปได้ใช่ไหม
ครับดู
หน้าแต่ถ้าแบงค์ใหญ่เกินไปก็ใส่ไม่ได้อ๋อ
โอเคอ๋อยอดเป็นแบงค์ลงไปเลยขอแบ่งก็รอให้
หน่อยค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้ออกแบงค์ร้อยใช่ไหม
เถอะ
เอาไปเลยครับๆโอเคขอบคุณค่ะ
อาหารยอดลงไปได้ครับจะมีขนาดใหญ่กว่าใหญ่
กว่าแบงค์ 20
ใช่แล้วก็หยอด
หนอๆออดได้เหมือนกันโอเคหาแล้วถ้าเราหยอด
ถ้าเรามีเงินแล้วยอดเงินลงไปเยอะและเยอะ
ยอดเงินลงไปเยอะเลยนะครับแล้วเงินมันเต็ม
กระปุกแล้วทำยังไงต่อครับเราก็จะ
แวะกระปุกขอ
ออกมาเอาไปก็
แค่เอาไปปากที่คานอ้าเดี๋ยวนะครับเฮียตี้
กำลังสงสัยแค่คืออะไรครับแคะคือการทำไหน
ค่ะ
อ๋ออ๋อคือการเปิดมันออกมาเปิดกระปุกออกมา
อ่อนไปมีรถ
เราไม่พูดว่าเปิด
ไม่ขอไปนิ้วค่อยๆแคะดึงแอนออกมาอ๋อ
[เพลง]
กู้เงินเงินเรียนก็ไหลออกมาจากกระปุกใช่
ไหมอ๋อเราก็เทเหรียญออกมา
ว้าวโว้ๆ
เลยนักเรียนมีเงินเยอะเลยเยอะมากเพราะมี
เงินเยอะเราทำเอาเงินไปทำอะไรครับเอาเงิน
ไปที่ไหนครับเอาไปที่ธนาคาร
ใต้แล้วเราก็เดินเข้าไป
ต่อไปใช่ไหม
แล้วก็เอาเงินเอาเงินไปเอาเงินไปฝากไปฝาก
ไว้ที่ธนาคารน่ะอ๋อโอเคนะครับใช่ค่ะวัน
นี้เราก็ได้รู้ไปว่าแบบนี้คนไทยเรียกว่า
แบงค์แบงค์ 5 เป็นชื่อเล่นนะเราเรียกชื่อ
เล่นเป็นแบบแบบนี้คนไทยเรียกว่า
เหรียญเหรียญเหรียญเหรียญบาทหน้าเหรียญ 5
บาท
เหรียญ 10 บาทตะเข้
แต่งว้าวนะครับหน้าวันนี้เราเรียนรู้
เรื่องเงินกันน่ะเดี๋ยวถ้านักเรียนมี
โอกาสมาที่ประเทศไทยนักเรียนก็จะได้ใช้
เงินของคนไทยใช้แบงค์ของคนไทยได้อย่างถูก
ต้องนะอ้าเพราะว่านะรู้จักแล้ววันนี้รู้
จักรู้จักแบ่งๆโป้ไทยแล้วรู้จักเงินเงิน 5
โอเคเงินนักเรียนออกเสียงคำว่าเงินได้ไหม
ครับเงิน
เงินนะแค่หาเงินออกอ่ะ
โอเคอ่ะต่อไป
มีอะไรแนะนำนักเรียนอีกบ้างครับวันนี้
ตอนนี้มีอะไรอีกไหมกันคลิปหน้าดีกว่าค่ะ
พี่อาร์ตี้วันนี้หมดแล้วไม่มีอะไรแนะนำ
แล้วเดี๋ยวคลิปหน้ากลับมาเจอกันใหม่อ้า
กับไปแล้ว
โอเคดูกันว่าเครียดอี้กับเตรียมจะมาพูด
คุยเกี่ยวกับเรื่องอะไรนะโอเคโอเคอ่าได้
เลยถ้างั้นเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าก็มาเจอกันนะ
ครับวันนี้สวัสดีครับน่าดูค่ะพี่สวัสดี
น้องเรียมอาสวัสดีนักเรียนด้วยผมเรียนตาย
ม.ค